-So now we have our keynote.
But rather than
have keynote speech,
we have keynote recast
as a conversation.
so we're very lucky to
have Janet Mock here, who
is a writer, cultural
commentator, advocate
for trans rights,
among other things.
[APPLAUSE]
-So I guess I should say that
my first introduction to Janet
was when she gave a
speech the my daughter's
graduation in Pitzer last year.
And I was on the edge of my
seat, where I was actually
very impressed with
the whole concept
of multiple intersections
of narrative
for how people
define themselves.
And I thought, this is the
person we want for the keynote.
So that was what convinced me.
She's also the author of
the autobiographical work,
Redefining Realness,
which my daughter gave me
for a Christmas present.
And I read, hanging
on every word.
And since this conference was
about language and gender,
I was also noting that she has
this exquisite ear and ability
to put into words different
forms of language.
So I guess we'll get
into her background.
But I just noted
for example, the way
he was able to capture a
kind of a matriarchal African
American dialect in Dallas, but
also kind of a trans language
that the one finds in Hawaii.
And it was just an amazing
journey for me to read this.
So I'm just saying I have
all these kind of markings
and underlines in
the book for that.
And interviewing
Janet is Moia Bailey,
who's a Dean's Fellow of Women's
Gender and Sexuality Studies
at Northeastern.
And we'll be interviewing Janet
as a kind of fire side chat.
And also uses her book as one of
the texts in her gender studies
class.
I had the great
privilege of having
a chance to chat with Moia
about this conference.
And I'll just turn
it over to Moia,
and I think it's going
to be a great session.
Thank you.
-Thanks, John.
-Thank you all for
coming and being here.
-I know.
Thank you.
-I'm really excited
to talk to you.
-Me too.
-So I wanted to start with
the book, because I too,
fell in love with the
book after reading it.
I read it in one sitting.
And I was like, I know I need
to assign this to my women's
studies students because the
way that you talk about language
and gender, and sexuality
and race in really,
really nuanced ways.
But also in an accessible way.
I love that, and
my students do too.
-Thank you for that.
-You're welcome.
So Redefining Realness invokes
the language of clear in trans
communities.
And you write that
realness is the ability
to be seen as hetero normative,
to assimilate, to not
be read as other, or
deviate from the norm.
Realness means you
are extraordinary
in your embodiment of what
society deems normative.
To embody realness, rather
than performing or competing
realness, enables trans
women to enter spaces
with a lower risk
of being rebutted,
or questioned,
policed, or attacked.
Realness is a
pathway to survival.
And I just thought that
was a wonderful quote.
And giving people the
opportunity to take a
look at that.
How does your work continue
to redefine realness
for yourself and for others?
-What's so interesting,
is the first time
I ever heard the term realness
was in Paris is Burning.
And I remember watching
it with girlfriends,
and we were teenagers, and just
kind of getting our entire life
from it.
Because we had never
seen parts of ourselves
reflected in a mainstream
product, in that kind of way.
Supposedly everyone saw
this when it came out.
And we couldn't believe
that these women existed
in another space beyond our own.
That they were being
recorded and archived,
and their living history
was there and existed.
And we know how
powerful that is.
I remember when
Dorian Corey, who's
kind of like the
matriarch-- there's
a lot of matriarchs, a
lot of mothers of houses
in that film-- seeing
her break down the,
not just the definition of
realness, which I shared there,
which is mostly linked
to being able to pass
in a dominant cisgender and
white and for New York City
street kids, rich society.
Being able to walk
on Park Avenue
and not have anyone clock
you, as we would say.
So as [INAUDIBLE]
passing so strongly.
But for me, I think
the way that I've
tried to redefine realness
is to take it away
from just this idea of being
able to blend in as cisgender,
as non-trans, and
to kind of say what
is authentic and real to us.
Because I think that so
often for trans folk,
we're constantly-- and I
think even see this now
in a lot of movement
spaces-- we're
constantly trying
to just create space
to talk about just call me my
name, called me my pronouns.
And let me just respect that.
And so a lot of our arguments
are around language.
And as someone in media, I
expect to argue around language
oftentimes, because I'd dealing
as a public facing person,
talking on behalf of an
entire community of people
that are completely diverse.
And so for me,
realness is about kind
of taking it more internal.
What is real to me?
And that's truth
and that's fact.
And no one gets to tell
you what real is for you.
What is authentic?
And no one gets to then
legitimize your truth.
And so that's what the
journey of writing that book
has often been about.
And that's what my work is.
Constantly battling
with at times,
because I find myself
in conversations
where-- I remember going
on The Colbert Report.
And he couldn't like,
his mind around the idea
that there's more than
he, she and her, hers.
And just was mind boggling.
And so like to have to do
that in mainstream spaces
to folk who are not initiated
in our conversations
around gender, is kind
of the multi-layered part
of some of that work.
-And I'm so grateful
for your text
as being a place where
you can send people now.
So that you don't have to
do that education work.
And talk to people.
-That gets me in
trouble too sometimes.
Because I'm like, I
don't do 101, I'm sorry.
-Read the book.
Read the book.
But related to
that, realness also
makes me think about the
way you talk about passing.
And I wanted to play a clip, if
people can queue the clip where
you're talking about
what passing means,
and how it is being used
in ways that don't actually
talk about the realities
of trans lives.
-I am woman.
I live my life as
a woman, and that's
how I should be perceived.
I'm not passing as
anything, I'm being.
Being myself.
I have such a
complicated relationship
with the concept
of passing, period.
Not even applying it to
my own life, but just
the idea that to pass
means that you're passing
is something that you're not.
Passing comes off as if you are
actively, because it's a verb.
You're actively engaging in some
kind of trickery or deception.
And so that's where I get
irritated with passing,
because any time that
I walk on the street
my gender is visible.
I am a woman.
People see me and
take me as a woman.
And that is not passing,
that's me just being.
But once I disclose that
I am trans, things change.
And then I become an oddity.
I become an object.
Something that is
objectified and gawked over.
And my humanity and
womanhood is then
checked and put into question.
So I can just imagine
someone who does not
have the conditional privilege
of passing having to have
to deal with that all the time.
So those are the
layered relationships
with the lived experiences
of being a woman that
is often seen as cis.
-I hate watching
videos of myself.
It's so bizarre.
And so the book hadn't come out
yet, and me and my boyfriend
at the time, Aaron,
who's now my husband,
he was like, we should
probably do some little video
things of you.
Just introduce what some of
the themes of the book are.
And I remember we did that.
And he did that dress thing.
That was me primping.
That wasn't supposed
to be captured.
But I just dedicating
myself to realness.
I just let it be a part
of the conversation.
-I think that is what
people love about you
and what you bring
to the conversation.
And taking that conversation
a little further,
I want to just read
a bit of your quote
about passing from the text.
And you say, "these thoughts
surrounding identity, gender,
bodies, and how we view,
judge, and objectify all women
brings me to the
subject of passing.
A term based on an assumption
that trans people are passing
as something they're not.
It's rooted in the
idea that we are not
really who we say we are.
That we are holding a secret,
that we are living false lives.
Examples of people passing in
media, whether through race,
imitation of life and
Nella Larsen's passing,
and class and gender,
are often portrayed
as leading a life
of tragic duplicity
and as deceivers who
will be punished harshly
by society when their true
identity is uncovered.
This is no different
for trans people
who pass as their gender, or
more accurately are assumed
to be cis or blend
in as cis, as if that
is the standard or the norm.
This pervasive thinking
frames trans people
as illegitimate and unnatural.
If a trans women who knows
herself operates in the world
and is seen as a woman,
perceived, treated,
and viewed as a woman, isn't
she just being herself?
She isn't passing,
she's merely being."
And I love that
piece of it because I
think you're calling out the
ways that we make assumptions
about gender as cis people,
and our expectations of what
we imagine difference
and other to be.
And so do you see more
people challenging
this concept of passing, now
that you've talked about it?
Now that people have
access to the book?
-I hope so.
I don't know if I've
seen that, but I
don't think it's only cis
people who make assumptions
around folks as gender and
pronouns and identities.
I make assumptions all the time.
I remember the other night there
was a non-binary professor who
was in this space at
another talk I was giving.
And I just assumed because I
saw lipstick and curly hair,
and kind of a non-conforming
experience of femininity
that I was like oh, so
maybe I'll complementing her
by saying she and her.
And then I was like, wait.
Are your pronouns she and her?
And then they said, no it's not.
It's they, them, theirs.
That's what I would prefer.
And then I apologized
for making assumptions.
So even though I'm talking
about these topics, and the way
that we need to break this
down and stop assuming,
I still make assumptions
on a daily basis.
And we all kind of do it.
And so for me, the idea
of-- I hope that people
are challenging that.
And continuing to
interrogate, and maybe
stop a bit of their
inclinations or instincts
to just completely like
assume immediately.
I never liked passing because it
always felt as if I am passing,
then is someone else failing?
And so I feel as
if I did nothing
to have to present
the way that I do.
To have the things that I have
that enable me access to quote,
unquote "pass this test."
And folks may not have that.
And so the conditional privilege
of being able to blend in.
I would prefer us not to
talk about passing too much.
But I understand that it is
a privilege that I do have.
The fact that not only do I
pass as a cis gender woman,
but I am also fall into the
line of what we consider
to be an attractive woman.
Because we also
have to unpack that.
Because some people
be like, well,
the fact they you're pretty,
doesn't that help you?
And it's like, well yeah,
pretty privilege is real
and passing privilege
is real, but they're not
one and the same.
You can have both.
They can stack them.
You can be a trans person
that does not pass, does not
blend in, but is gorgeous.
Like LaVerne Cox would tell me
in conversation all the time.
She's like, I know that
I'm a beautiful woman,
but I don't pass.
I don't blend in as cisgender.
And so even all of
that stuff and trying
to unpack those layers
of like all of that.
But I don't want to completely
just throw out passing,
because I also understand
that it's a part of systems.
The way in which people make
often make assumptions about me
based on the way that
I present, and how
I'm passing all of these tests.
And that it enables
me access into spaces
to be seen and heard on the
levels that I'm seen and heard.
-And I think that piece-- one of
the things that hasn't happened
so much yet in the
conversation is
looking at the intersections
of both the ways
that gender and race
and class come together.
So what I love about
your definition
is that you also think about
class as a form of passing.
You give the example
of Joe Millionaire
and some of the shows
where people are also
quote, unquote "passing" as
being in a different class
category.
And I wonder if you'd maybe
you want to talk about that.
How does intersectionality
show up in your life?
-Oh my god.
How does it show up in my life?
I think about even
the way that I speak.
I think I may have talked
about it little bit in terms
of in the book about this
idea of my mother telling me
I couldn't speak
Hawaiian Pidgin The way
in which all of my friends
and my older siblings,
and my grandmother spoke.
We were always around her.
And my mom was like you're
not going to speak in Pidgin.
You're going to
speak proper English.
And so being able to
speak proper English when
I went to the
mainland, most times
I wasn't marked as
being from Hawaii
or having something that
denoted-- because also pigeon
denoted class too.
The fact that I
didn't come-- like I
could speak some of the
buzz terms in academia.
I could speak some of the
buzz terms in feminism
and transness, and
all of these things
that then enabled me to
kind of be accepted as OK,
so you're passing this test.
So we all come from
the same space.
Like no, but we don't
come from the same space.
Like I come from the streets
of Oakland, and Dallas,
and Hawaii.
And I have all these
things, but I've shedded,
I've learned to shed all
these things in order
to then now fit into this
very class, monied space.
Like for example, for you
from NYU or People Magazine,
or whatever the
spaces that I go into.
Or as a TV presenter,
or a TV host.
I speak in a way that people
are comfortable hearing.
And it doesn't necessarily
represent where all of I
come from.
-And do you; think
you shed those things?
Or do you think that
you make decisions
about when you deploy them?
-I think because it was so
much a part of my survival,
it's become part of just
the way that I present I am.
But when I'm around
family, it's different.
So in different spaces,
you show up oftentimes
not as a different
person, but you present
and you feel comfortable
enough to show that.
So in intimate space, the
intimate space of family,
I can speak Hawaiian
Pidgin, and I
feel comfortable doing that
because no one will judge me.
They understand that
that is an entry in.
That is how we speak.
That is for us.
And that's what language is.
-And that leads me
to another question
that I was going to ask later.
But it how do you
decide what language
is appropriate for what spaces?
As black people, we
talk a lot about code
switching and making
decisions about what we say
and when we don't say it.
Do you think that there are
some gendered language that
is specifically for communities
that shouldn't be shared,
and shouldn't go further?
Because I remember watching
a video where you're making
a decision about the title.
And that there was
maybe a moment where you
were going to call it Go Fish.
Is that right?
-Fish Food.
-Fish Food, yes.
And so making a decision
not to use that term
was that also about who
you wanted to have access
to that language?
-I think so.
But going back to the
intersection, really quick.
So even the idea passing.
So yes, I can pass and blend
in as a cisgendered woman
in the world.
But also the layer
of race comes in.
So I'm passing as--
and that offers
me to pass-- to be able to
blend in as a cis woman.
Enables me a level of
safety that other trans
women who are not able to
blend in as easily as I do
don't have.
But then the next layer
of that is I'm also pass.
And so that's a test
that I am passing there.
I'm still perceived as a
then cisgender black woman.
I don't know how safe cisgender
black women are in the world.
And so these are things where
it's like a lot of people
will-- even within
trans spaces--
they'll be like oh, she's
pretty and she passes.
So no wonder she's-- she OK.
Like she's already hit.
And it's like no.
We cannot then separate my
transness from my blackness.
Like that's all a
part of who I am.
And just because you may have
an agenda of what you believe
is the hierarchical
nature of quote unquote
"oppression olympics"
doesn't mean
that you can then negate
the fact that I am still
a black trans
women in the world.
So going back to the
talking about when
I make-- I think
your question was
when do I make the decisions?
Or Fish Food.
We'll just go with that.
So my friend Wendy, and
who's a huge character
in the book, and also just a
huge presence in my life, still
to this day, you just
call your book Fish Food.
And fish is equated
within I think
trans circles, ballroom
circles, queer spaces,
mostly trans girl spaces though.
Like oh, she's
serving fish today.
Meaning like catch of
the day, you're fresh,
you're everything.
And we've seen that go
outside of that space
and be seen as something
completely different.
So now it's seen
as misogynistic.
It's seen as a judgment
of women's or people
having vaginas.
A judgment on
vaginas, which is then
a judgment of
women, which is seen
as sexist and misogynistic.
And so for me, as I realize
that the danger of just having
this term go out, because
this book exists in spaces
I have no control
over, I no longer
wanted that term, which came
from my own first hearing it
at 13 years old.
Like, ooh girl,
you're serving fish.
I didn't want that
to then be a judgment
call on all trans folks,
specifically all trans women,
specifically all
trans women of color.
What are those dynamics?
And so I chose realness,
because I felt it was something
that someone could
see and kind of maybe
understand what it meant.
And then maybe then get
some depth of knowledge,
in terms of speaking about that.
Or getting what the
book's themes are.
-That's brilliant.
One of the words that
came up a lot last night
was, someone said that the words
of the comedian were perfect.
And I think sometimes you really
have perfect language that gets
us to the heart of the matter.
-I feel like they're imperfect.
Because even the idea of--
I remember when-- and that's
the one of things that there's
certain groups of folk who
are looking to find your
flaws, find your imperfections.
And something that thinking
about fish food for example
is one of those things
that's pulled out.
Some people are like,
you're not a feminist
because you use this word
fish to describe all women.
No, this is a language.
This is a term that came out
of a very specific community.
It was more trans
women were trying
to-- womanhood was our goal.
To be able to pass
and blend, that
was the goal at the time
when I was 12 years old.
That was the holy grail.
Was be able to be seen as the
woman I knew myself to be.
And it had no idea-- most of
us had never been with women.
We wouldn't have known
what-- but like that
has become one of those things
where it consistently comes up.
Where it's like, well,
she calls women fish.
And it's like, no, we were
calling ourselves fish.
And we were not
seen as real women,
and you don't see us
as real women anyway.
So it was unreal women
calling each other a fish.
Calling each other an animal.
Plus, I'm a Pisces.
So I am a fish.
-Which I would love
to talk about more.
But I do want to move on to
a bit of your pop culture
side of yourself.
So as a pop culture journalist
and longtime Beyonce fan,
what are your thoughts
about the words and voices
of Messy Mia and Big Freedia?
And not their faces in
the video Formation?
And so for those who don't
know, Messy Mia and Big Freedia
are gender non-conforming
black people
who have definitely a
presence in New Orleans,
and have brought a lot
of the cultural tradition
of black queer and trans
spaces to the mainstream.
-I'm sad that their faces
and their images are not--
I don't know of Messy
Mia is still with us?
-Right.
She's not.
-Yeah.
But Big Freedia is.
She's a center of
her own reality show,
that I believe is
past season 3 now.
So this is someone
that I would have
loved to see get information.
To really have someone's--
not just their work in it,
but then also to have your
work cited and to be seen,
I think is powerful.
It would have introduced
millions of people
to her, to her presence, to
an uncomfortable presence.
To really push the
boundaries of what
we say in this specific space,
which I believe that Beyonce
was doing with Formation,
was this unapologetic space
of blackness.
It would even
challenge black folk
to say that this is
also a black person too.
-Yes.
-Right?
-Someone that we're
going to also protect.
Someone that's also
being harassed,
not only by police
and systems, and all
of points of oppression, but
also within her own people,
within our own community.
And so that would've been
something that I think
would have trickled
down to some trans girls
being able to feel as if they've
seen a part of themselves
in this visual unapologetic
celebration of blackness.
But on the other hand, I
do love that Beyonce made
such a political statement.
For me, I've known
Beyonce for 17 years
now, through pop
culture and television.
Specifically through TRL.
And I was always surprised
that for some reason
white people were watching
it, and they were just like,
they were surprised that
she was black or something.
It was like, did you not see
her in Tina Knowles' Originals,
like when she was 15 years old.
Did you do not see her with
a hot comb in her hand.
Like did you do not
see the fact that she
was in a black girl group?
And what you kind of
realize after a while is
that once someone becomes
famous and they are deemed
as part of their famousness
is that they can then quote,
unquote "transcend race."
And so the power to
me about Formation,
about her releasing
the video, about her
[INAUDIBLE] using all of
America's number 1 watched
show, televised event,
she was like, oh no,
just so you guys remember,
my dad's from Alabama.
My mother's from Louisiana.
I'm a black girl.
A southern black girl,
which is a particular type
of blackness, which I know that
even you were talking about.
Just her kind of being like
this is a southern blackness.
Like even that is
complicated in its own thing.
But even thinking
about folk who've
then transcended blackness,
OJ, or someone like that.
I obsessed with OJ,
because I didn't live it
when it happened.
So now that the ethics thing
is out, I'm like, oh my god.
At night deep diving
into all of the evidence,
trying to figure out-- I get it.
That was a long tangent,
but-- yeah, let me stop.
I don't know where
I'm going with that.
-Well I do think that
that's an important--
-Oh, well, even within
those spaces, right?
Like respectable blackness.
Right?
Often times, southern
black does not
seen as respectable blackness.
-Absolutely.
-Right.
So thinking about those
layers of all that.
So I can be like, I'm
just a black girl,
but I'm a southern black girl.
To root herself in that, and
then that women have always
been-- black women have
always been in formation
when it comes to fighting
for all of our people, right?
-Yes.
And those nuances
really come to the fore
when do you look
at race and gender
together, which is sometimes
people don't do and talk
about gender in a vacuum.
Which makes these
assumptions about what
are the races at the gendered
people we're talking about.
And related to that,
I wonder if you
might say a bit about
the words that people
say that perpetuate unsafe
environments for our folks.
Specifically, for queer
and trans people of color.
How do you see the
language that we
use every day reframing
or making assumptions
about who people are?
-I think one of the, just
maybe centering queer and trans
folk of color, just
the idea of LGBTQ.
Just that as an acronym.
Oftentimes there's
a certain portrait
of what we consider to
be what LGBT is, right,
when people hear that.
It's become its own
brand of something,
and the mainstreaming of that
has often time equated that
to white cisgender gay men.
And their needs, and what
their priorities are.
It doesn't necessarily think
about the LGBTQ homeless youth,
right, who are on the
streets, who have nothing.
Who only have their bodies.
Who are engaged in sex trade.
Who are trying to survive.
Who are dealing with nonprofit
industrial complex and all
of these things.
We're not talking
about them, right?
And so for me, I
often think about just
like the labeling of that
oftentimes is so reductive.
I'm glad that it may bring the
whole diverse group of people
together and make it
seem as if there's
this one solid community and
this one singular movement.
But I know this acronym to be a
lot more diverse and plentiful.
It's pluralities are
not communicated often.
The sense, even within T.
I have said this so many times.
I am not an advocate
or an activist
for transgender people.
Because I cannot, in this
single body with this single
experience, advocate for
all transgender people,
because I don't know all
transgender experiences.
I am still learning, just
from my own assumption.
The other night, of that
professor's gender identity
and pronouns.
Non-binary experiences are--
some are reflective of my own,
but they're not.
Because even me,
my own narrative
is one that has
often been held up
as a kind of
narrative we tell when
it comes to transsexual bodies.
Like this experience of
medically and socially
transitioning from
one part of the binary
to another part of the binary.
But there's folk who don't
feel the need to do that.
So I can speak for all
transgender people.
And I've always centered
transwomen within my work,
but because things are
taken out of my own control,
and my words and my labels
are not even asked of me.
Like when I do interviews,
I'm then the voice of.
And we've seen how dangerous
it is for folk to be
seen as the voice of community.
I work alongside my communities.
I speak alongside
my communities.
-That was great.
I'm a leave it there.
-But words and language, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Exactly.
-No pronouns.
I know your question
was about-- not
pronouns but abuse and violent
language that is often used.
-Right.
Well, related to pronouns.
One of the things
that's happening now
is people are having
a conversation
about the use of cis versus
the use of non trans.
And that's happening both
within community and outside,
making decisions about
which language is preferred.
Do you have any
thoughts about what
you would prefer people use?
-I don't have-- my thing
is if we're consistently
always labeling the thing
that is seen as not normal,
or that deviates from the norm,
I find that to be an issue.
-Yeah.
-I was going to equate race,
but I'm not going to do that.
I'm not doing that today.
Thinking about the
sense of-- I forgot
who I was speaking
to about this,
but you don't have
to identify as cis.
Do you know what I mean?
Just like a transperson doesn't
have to identify as trans.
I know many transwomen, once
they've transitioned and are
just living their lives,
they don't identify as trans.
They just identify as women.
But it doesn't
take the fact away
that a part of their
experience is trans.
But that may not be the way
that they will then identify.
So for cisgender
people it's like, you
don't have to
identify as cisgender,
but cisgender is how we
describe your experience, that
is not a trans experience.
-Mhm.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-And so for me,
I always struggle
with a sense of, oh,
this thing is different,
so let's label that, and
then this will be the normal.
So this is the normal
here, and everything else
will then be labeled.
-That is definitely part
of the problem, for sure.
-But then also
thinking about-- I
remember my brother
read the book, my book,
and he's talking about,
he was just like,
well I am a cisgender
black, you know.
And thinking about
also how language can
shut a lot of people out, too.
Even now, cis is not a
term that most people
outside of academia or outside
of like queer and trans
circles and social spaces
understand or know quite yet.
-Right.
-And so if I'm having
a conversation--
if my grandmother was
still alive and said,
you're cisgender.
My grandmother's bold
and she's up front,
so she'd be like what is that?
Some people will just
nod, and then they'll
like shut off a conversation.
They're probably
thinking in their mind,
I don't know this word, so this
must mean something about me
that I don't know this word.
I think about that,
oftentimes, and so I
think that's why
within my memoir,
I went to work at explaining
words that a lot of folk--
or, thinking about
my 12-year-old self,
didn't even I didn't even
use the word transgender.
I didn't know that
transgender was what I was.
And so I always went back
to that, how would I then,
if I'm writing this
book, not for the world
but for that 12-year-old
transgirl who maybe doesn't
even know what trans is yet.
I need to then break
everything down for her.
And not so much teach her about
how she should properly speak
or the terms she should
know, but more of, this
is the way that the world
is talking about you.
-And speaking of your
12-year-old girl self.
One of the things I really
love is your incredible piece,
"The Free Girl Who Is
Everything" in The Feminist
Utopia.
And I have one more quote here.
"In her world, the words
'girls' and 'women' do not need
qualifiers.
She will not furrow
her brow wondering
if her interlocking
identities are
ingrained in its definition.
Because of her foremothers--
Sylvia, and Audre, Barbara,
and Marsha-- she will no longer
be burdened by the question
Sojourner Truth had to ask--
'Ain't I a woman?' When she
hears 'girls' and 'women,'
Marissa Alexander, Gwen Araujo,
Renisha McBride, CeCe McDonald',
Island Nettles, Zoraida Reyes,
her sisters in Nigeria,
are all included.
She will never doubt
their inclusion, or hers."
And I thought that was
such a beautiful vision.
And I'm wondering,
how do we get there?
What are the things
that need to shift
to help us create the
world for this girl,
and the world for
your 12-year-old self?
-I'm always challenged by that.
I'm often invited
into spaces where
it's like, we're gonna talk
about the status of women
and girls.
And I remember that piece
coming out of a part of a speech
that I gave at the
foundation, where
one of the
presidential candidates
was giving the keynote.
And it was all about
making a statement
around the global status and
condition of women and girls.
And I always feel as if
transwomen are rarely
a part of that.
Like, we're not talking
about transgirls,
we're not talking about
a girl with a penis.
We're not talking about a
girl that is in transition.
girl that is-- so for me
and my work, that's
who I center.
And so I was like,
how do I bring her
into this conversation,
but also link her,
because I'm also a
black transwoman.
I'm also a black transwoman
who engaged in the sex trade
as a teenager to
take care of myself
in a world that wasn't
taking care of me.
How do I bring her as a
part of a lineage of women,
as Kitchen Table: Women of Color
Press Barbara Smith would say,
third world women.
So how do I bring
her within that.
Not so much to say that
transwomen are over here
and all other women
are there, but to say
that she's a part of, even
when we say girls and women,
these girls and women
are not centered.
These girls and women,
when they're missing,
they're not on the covers
of People magazine.
And so that's where
that space came from.
How do we do that?
I think it's
realizing that we have
to take it beyond our
own, limited experiences
and perceptions of what
is deemed my experience.
Who goes away from that?
Who doesn't quite fit
that experience for you?
So if you're saying girls,
define what girls is to you.
And then, how then do
we interrogate that,
and then to challenge that
and then to open that up.
And then how do we bring
the most oftentimes
marginalized folk center.
Like Bell Hooks said,
the margin's the center.
How do we bring those
folk in, and then
realize that by centering those
most marginalized, those often
silenced and invisiblized
in many of our conversations
and spaces and policies
and all those things.
When we center them, we
then become more liberated.
-Mhm.
Deep breath on that, yeah.
Yes.
How do we do that?
-How do you do-- no, that
what I wanted to ask you.
-Well, I mean.
I think language is
a big piece of that.
Giving people access
to language that
helps them see that there
are other possibilities
is a big piece.
So, again, going
back to your text,
I think that the book
gives people access
to language they wouldn't
have had access to before.
I think that's one
place that it moves,
and in popular
culture and media.
That's another
place where people
get the opportunity to
see a different reality,
and I'm really
encouraged by the things
that people are
creating for themselves.
And that makes me think,
too, about your hashtag,
#girlslikeus.
Creating spaces
and using language
to make space where
there isn't any.
Do you want to talk about
the origins of #girlslikeus
and how you've seen it shift?
-I feel like I had some
random thought that
came with it that was really,
really poignant, but I lost it.
But going on to #girlslikeus.
Twitter was a different
thing in 2012.
I joined Twitter 2009.
And I remember just
wanting to have
a space where I could
talk about certain things,
and folk not necessarily knowing
what I was talking about.
But then folk that do
know what that spaces,
they'll get it and know.
And then they can engage.
And so it was just for me,
when I hashtag #girlslikeus.
It was a space where
transgirls could come together
and transwomen could
come together and talk
about their issues, their
resources, share resources,
share experiences, have a
sounding board, link up,
and what I've seen is
that it's led to real life
friendships for people.
Even in my own space, because
I created that hashtag,
I connected with people.
I connected with
other transwomen
who are now friends of mine.
Deep, deep deep, friends who
I had never known before I
created that hashtag.
And I've seen that
happen for other folk,
so it was like a connector.
It's not something
that I even have
to deal with-- I
don't even use it
as often as I used to, because
now it has its own world.
It's a part of other
people's lives.
They put it in
their Twitter bios,
instead of saying
blatantly, I'm a transwoman,
they just say #girlslikeus.
It's a wink and a nod.
The girls know.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-It's like that's
what it's become.
-I was really excited
to see it in Her Story.
There's a moment where
the two characters
talk about #girlslikeus.
-And that's the
power of creating
the stories and the
images and the words
and the sounds that
represent who you are.
Her Story is a project that was
created by Jen Richards, who
is a transwoman, and
starring Jen Richards,
and my other friend
Angelica Ross.
We met through #girlslikeus.
That's how we met.
I was going to a speaking
engagement in 2012 in Chicago.
And I remember meeting them,
and I DM'd them through Twitter.
And was just like,
let's get together.
And so they became friends
because I linked them together.
So it was a great connector.
That's what #girlslikeus is.
-You are a great connector.
Because you also connected me
to a friend here in Boston.
You're good at that, and
Twitter is a great space for--
-I don't even like
people that much.
I think because I
do media work, it
seems like I'm so
outgoing and social.
But it's more like I'd rather
be at home reading or binge
watching something else.
-Ohh.
What are you binge watching?
-I told you, the OJ stuff.
Because I didn't live
it the first time.
It's just so layered,
there's so much stuff there.
I didn't really have a
relationship to him, period,
because I was too young.
So when they were
like, OJ Simpson,
even when I was watching
the OJ Simpson FX series,
I was like, why was
he such a big deal.
I didn't know that
having a Hertz commercial
was a big deal.
But seeing how he also
then didn't really
have black folk in his life
beyond his family, right.
Like he was one of those
folks that believed,
one of those public
black people that
believe that I can
transcend race,
and I'm just-- the line in
the series is, I'm not black,
I'm OJ.
I was captivated by that.
And so then I just wanted to
see in like what was going on,
and the layers of the
domestic violence,
and how they could
pick the jury.
That black women were going
to side with their-- the thing
that they always
do to black women
is they're going to sign with
their gender, over their race,
because he beat this woman.
And then the next layer of folk
saying, well, Johnnie Cochran,
he married a white woman, and
black women don't like that,
when our successful black--
and so all of these layers.
And then also, again, people
talking for black women
would not necessarily
actually listening to what
they would think about this.
So anyway, all those layers.
-And layers, layers
within layers,
makes me think,
too, about what are
the words-- what are the things
that you're excited about now?
How do you see people using
words and find new ways?
Is there anything
that's exciting you
about the way that
language and words are
moving in this moment?
-Yeah.
So what excites me, is the fact
that we all, now, have access.
Our phones are like
extensions of ourselves,
and they carry so
much stuff on them.
And so the fact
that I'm constantly
communicating with people
on Snapchat, on Twitter,
on Tumblr.
I can follow a Tumblr
tag and may not
understand what
it's talking about,
but will be taught that
day about someone else's
experience.
I feel like because we
have tools to create,
we can now broadcast our lives.
We don't need to wait for
a network or a producer
to come and tell us, I want
to do a story on your life.
No, I do a story of
my life every day.
And so in that way,
I no longer have
to look at mainstream media
to represent and reflect me.
I can go to a hashtag and find
more people that reflect me.
I can find my people.
And then I can find
myself, and then I
can be empowered because I found
my people and myself to then
share myself with the world.
And so then we get more
words, and more definitions,
and some people may have
a different definition
for certain word, or an
identity, or an acronym.
Or a letter, whatever it is.
And so we get closer
and closer to,
I think, multi-layered
truths that
will be in contradiction
and then in relationship to
and-- I would even thinking
about-- I would say a year ago,
or maybe when I even
wrote Redefining Realness,
I saw the gender
binary as linear.
And now I understand it
more as a kaleidoscope.
It's all over the place.
Male and female
no longer get to--
or, men and women, or
masculine and feminine
no longer get to be
these ends, bookends.
They're no longer that.
They're just a part of
this wider collection.
And no one is
doing this anymore.
No one's in the middle.
You know what I mean?
I'm over here, she's over
there, they are over here,
zey is over there.
That's what it is, and people
have to get comfortable
with that, because as we
have these tools to broadcast
our lives, there's
be more people,
there'll be more voices.
More definitions, more words.
-But how do we get there?
-What do you mean
how do we get there?
-How do we get to the
place where people
are more comfortable with that?
Kaleidoscope
-I think the number
one thing is,
we are all really-- My
grandmother told me a long time
ago, don't worry about what
people think about you,
because there's just going
to think about themselves
a couple seconds later.
And so the fear
in that, the fact
that like someone over there
identifies as such and such.
The way that they identify
does not threaten the way
that I identify.
It takes nothing away
from me, the fact
that this person
over there identifies
as a non-binary
asexual crip dancer.
That is who they are.
-Right.
-That has nothing to do with me.
And I think that people are
uncomfortable, because they're
trying to make it about them.
All you have to do
is just understand
that that's their identity.
That's their pronouns.
Them choosing their
pronouns doesn't take away
your use of pronouns.
Yes, you have to adapt
your language a bit
when you speak with that person.
But other than that, they're
moving on with their lives.
It has nothing to do with you.
It doesn't threaten
your identity.
your pronouns.
It doesn't read your bathrooms
-And that's the piece that
people keep coming up with,
that feeling of
being threatened.
I don't know if you've seen
The Prancing Elites, about--
-Love them.
And I remember seeing
an episode in which--
and for those who don't
know, Prancing Elites
are a dance team, and they do
a style dance called J-setting.
They're based in Alabama.
And one of the
episodes I saw was
a man who was
really uncomfortable
with them dancing.
And he said, I don't like men
wearing these kinds of clothes.
-Then don't wear those clothes!
That's my--
-Exactly.
But that was his thing.
He was like, it makes
me uncomfortable.
-Why?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
I wonder, do you
want to say anything
before we open it up to--
-No.
---questions?
So if people have questions,
and want to come to the front.
I would ask that people actually
ask questions, not comments,
and we'll take a couple
of questions at a time.
And then you can decide.
We'll maybe take two or three.
We'll hear the question,
and then you can-- yeah?
-That sounds good.
-One of the things I've
always loved about your work
is that it's always seemed to
me as though, although you're
talking about
transgender and you're
talking about sexuality and
race, et cetera, in some ways
it's really about people
accepting who they are,
and accepting other people.
Allowing other people,
and accepting other people
being who they are.
That whole thing about
being real that it's
about accepting
people, and that's
what's so thrilling about
it, is that the more
we can have a
country and a world
where people accept who they
are and accept other people.
Beyond the issues
of sex, or race,
or whatever else, religion.
So I just wondered if
you've thought about it
in those terms, as sort of the
broader issues of accepting
other people, just for who
they are in any space and time
and label.
-Yeah, sure.
Thank you-- you going to answer?
-Well I was going to
let one more person go,
or do you want to answer it?
-I'm just going to answer
one by-- I'll forget.
-OK.
-Then I'm going to go
off on the OJ tangent.
-OK.
-So for me, I think
that the first time that
was confronted with the idea
of how my work was being seen
was after the book went out.
But I remember when I
was being pre-interviewed
for my interview
with Oprah Winfrey,
they were talking about
all these universal themes
of my book.
Like about, everyone
has a struggle
with accepting themselves.
And I was like, yeah, I guess.
But that's not the
way that I wrote it.
And so I think that there
is universal themes that
come out of someone just
sharing their truth.
So I know in my own journey, it
was incredibly difficult for me
to even it accept my own self.
And then to share
that with, say,
my siblings, my mother,
my father, my best
friend, and then going
outside of that quote unquote
"safe space" and going into
the world of school, community,
volleyball team, college, and
thinking about how I wanted--
I guess maybe one of unconscious
intentions of writing the book
was to make folk
realize how hard
it is to just accept
your own truth.
And then to share it.
And then also knowing that
oftentimes, sharing your truth
can lead to exclusion
and violence and harm,
and all of those things.
And so hopefully
by breaking it down
in the way that I did
with my own experience,
it enables us all
to be a bit more
open when someone comes to
us with their own revelation.
Their own self revelation,
and feel safe enough
to share it with them.
And I hope that
that's what it does.
So I'm glad that
that's how you saw it.
Thank you.
-And if you could
say your name, too.
-My name's Emma
[? Kernan ?], I'm
a first year at
Brandeis University.
And I know you'll be at our
university in a few weeks,
actually, so I'm
looking forward to that.
As a first year, I've
had the opportunity
to be doing an
internship with one
of the scholars at the
Women's Research Center.
And we're doing research
around the use of language,
and the ways that you say it,
and the ways that you do it,
and how it can affect
feminist activism.
Janet Friedman is my scholar.
And one of the
questions that I've
been trying to do
research around,
is how forms of language,
specifically the hashtag,
how that can be used to
create a form of activism.
And I know as an
activist yourself
and an author and generally
very much involved in pop
culture, how do
you yourself find
the use of the hashtag
on Twitter and Tumblr
useful for promoting activism.
-I think it's a great
connector for information.
I know that oftentimes, I'll go
to-- the first thing I wake up
to is Twitter, and the
last thing I go to sleep to
is Twitter.
So I'm always in on
the conversation,
but when I'm sleeping
for my eight to 10 hours
that I need to look this way.
I wake up, and
something has gone off.
I remember the other night,
I woke up to #trapcovers.
And I was like what
are trap covers?
And then my entire life changed.
I don't know if that's--
-So great.
-You have to watch the
Adele one, it's so good.
-The "Bohemian Rhapsody,"
too, is really good.
-Oh yes, yes.
People may not see
that as activism,
but I think that
people wrote pieces
around this creation of
this particular hashtag,
and talked about
the layers of that.
Folk were going back to
Beyonce's "Formation,"
white people were
singing acoustic versions
of "Formation."
And then black
people were like, OK,
well then, what
we're going to do
is sing trap covers of your
favorite classics and songs.
And so it was this
great conversation
that was being had in this
public space around race,
around representation,
around what we believe
what pop culture creations
are ours, or yours,
or what are those lines.
And I think about
something like #sayhername,
which I know we didn't really
we didn't get to talk about.
But #sayhername is
one hashtag that now,
when a transwoman of
color is murdered,
what often tends to happen is
that-- an activist named Cerno
Biko, now hashtagged
it, because she's
a part of the
#blacklivesmatter network.
She then talks about the
lives of black transwomen,
oftentimes, who
have been murdered.
And she goes and does
activism with their families.
So she'll go to the
funeral to make sure
that they're not
so much trained,
but to make sure that
they use her pronouns.
And they don't dead name
her, and all of these layers
that happen after
these women are dead.
And so someone in the
community, through a hashtag,
was then empowered
to go out and do work
beyond just getting information.
But then to also create
this system that's not eve
funded yet, but this
system of resource and care
to care for families of color
who have trans daughters, who
don't even know how to
deal with the intersection
yet, because oftentimes these
girls were alone in the world.
They fled hostile homes.
And so there's now
a black transwomen
who goes and does that work,
because of that hashtag.
Do you know what I mean?
-Hi.
My name's Eleanor
[? McGordy ?], I'm
from McGill
University in Canada.
I study counseling psychology,
and I'm doing several research
projects on trans this year.
One thing I'm recently looking
at is media representations
and obviously social media is
a huge part of that nowadays.
My question pulls on
the themes of passing
versus failing, being an
advocate for trans verses
particular subgroups of the
trans asterisks larger group.
I came across a
YouTube video where
it was a trans African
American woman,
speaking about how she's now
deciding to detransition,
and she felt that she had been
tricked by women, transwomen
in the media and
transwomen celebrities
who were appearing like
goddesses and who were passing,
and who had more
positive experiences
than this woman, who
felt really continuously
rejected by society.
Sold her body, and was still
not passing and still felt
rejected, and
basically was saying
that she had been tricked.
So my question,
coming full circle,
is as you said,
passing is a privilege,
and being attractive and
beautiful is a privilege.
And having a voice for
that is a privilege.
For the people who don't have
that privilege, who don't pass
or who face lots of hardships
in their lives, how can we,
or how-- this is kind of an
impossible question, maybe,
but how can they
advocate for themselves
without that privilege?
Or how can we shape
a society that you
can have more of a frame
for less privileged people.
Let's say people who don't
pass, to have their own voice
and not just look to
people who are passing.
-I think that's an incredibly
convoluted question.
It's layered in so many ways.
Just in the framing
of it is problematic.
What it broadcasts to
this entire room, I think,
is problematic, too.
It's difficult for
me to then break
all of the layers of that down.
But I think that all women and
girls, not just transwomen,
are faced with impossible
images in media.
So let's not just say transwomen
are grappling with that.
Who are harming themselves
because of what the media has
created as the image.
So transwomen are
not only grappling
with the idea of wanting
to-- some transwomen,
we also have to be clear,
because not all transwomen's
goal is to pass.
I think that we are cognizant
that the system privileges
folks that do pass and blend in.
But I don't think that's
a goal for all transwomen.
I feel incredibly, deeply sad
that this woman felt that way,
and that was her journey.
But that is her journey.
I don't quite know it.
In terms of folk in media and
what the media representation
is, I think it's deeply flawed.
I don't believe, again, that
all transwomen who are in media
pass.
I think a lot of them
would say that they don't.
I do believe that a lot to
do subscribe and are allowed
into the room, because there's
a certain layer of what I would
say is acceptable femininity.
A femininity that
is often celebrated.
You can think about size.
You can think about the ways in
which grooming is a part of it.
Now do I believe that these
women are doing this in order
to cater to?
That I don't believe
that is a part of that.
I believe that they are
showing up as themselves,
and they are groomed in
the way that they believe
that they want to
present to the world,
and that is then
privileged and allowed in.
But in terms of how do
we create a world-- how
do we create a world, where--
right now what we're grappling
with in the movement, I
think, is daily access issues
for folk.
How are you resourced?
And one of the great ironies to
me is that transwomen of color
specifically embody many
different identities,
but rarely does all
those identities
and those communities
show up for them.
So we have feminist movements
that are dealing with gender.
We have LGBT movements which
are supposed to be tasked
with dealing with trans issues.
And we have racial justice
movements, oftentimes
that are not centered
around bodies that
are not cisgender black males.
And so there's no
coalition work in between,
because everyone
says, well that's
LGBT work that's supposed to
do with these trans people.
But in with the LGBT
stuff, oftentimes
the dominant narrative is
white, gay cisgender men.
So that's the great
tragedy, I believe,
in the existence for
transwomen of color.
And I think at this
particular woman,
based on what the
soundbites I just heard,
was dealing with a lot of
trauma every single day,
daily access trauma to
even leave their home.
And so I think people
don't even understand
what it takes for
people who are grappling
with living their truth
to just leave their home,
if they have a home.
And so, all of that stuff Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Hello, my name is Beckett.
I am a sophomore at Harvard.
And your definition
of realness sounds
like it could be
incredibly empowering,
and give you some strength
to help get through all
of the daily
barriers that come up
if you aren't a cis person,
if you want a white person.
My question is, what if you
struggle with identifying
who you are to yourself?
Because if realness is
who you are to yourself,
how can you be
real for yourself,
if you aren't really
sure who you are?
How do you address that?
-I think that, for me, that
was one of the my earliest
dissidences, was the idea
of the first things I
learned from my parents was that
I was a black child in America.
A poor black child in
America, grappling with that.
And then the idea of, and you're
also a boy child in America.
And this is who you are.
So getting these definitions
and labels from parents,
and then the work
for me came in.
A lot of the confusion,
and heartache, and trauma,
and policing that
I dealt with was
trying to be in that
space of not knowing,
and not being certain.
I think one of the first
things I write about the book
is around uncertainty
and embracing that.
As a young person, it
was hard to do that.
I can now, the person that
was 25 to 27 who wrote that,
could understand that.
But then for the four
to 12-year-old person,
it was incredibly difficult.
And I didn't have
the words then.
I didn't have the
definitions then.
And that's a part of the
self discovery process.
And for me, it
happened quite young,
that I was able to
face those things.
And find the people
that I needed to find,
and find my community
who helped me figure out
what that was for me.
What my identity
was, and who I was,
and the resources that
I would need to find
to be able to be who I am.
And some people, it
happens later on,
and it's a longer process.
And there's things
that are in the way,
and obligations that come
in, and family abuses,
and all of those things.
And so I think that that's just
part of self discovery process.
-Thank you so much.
-Hi, there.
My name's John Kelly.
I'm a first year grad student
in religion and trans theory
here at Harvard.
Something that I really
love is your friendship
with Laverne Cox,
and the way you
talk about your friend Wendy.
And so I was
wondering if you could
talk about what it means
to be a transperson,
or just a human person
doing this work in relation
to others, and the importance
of friendships and relationships
in being able to sustain
the work and inspire you.
-I don't think I'd be able to
do this work without my chosen
community and chosen family.
Wendy was someone I
met at 12-years-old,
and I don't really know what
my life would be without her.
So for me it's just an
integral part of my existence.
I don't know what
it would be if--
The thing I will say
about true community
is that I can show up empty,
and nothing is expected of me.
And I think that's the goal.
I take and I grapple with a lot,
in places that are not my home.
I'm taken out of my home and
brought to spaces like this
to speak and talk and grapple
with questions from folks.
I love being in
conversation with people.
But it takes a toll.
It's work.
And I get to then
go home and text
or call shadily Snapchat with
people that I love and care
about, and check in.
And so I think that because they
also do-- well, Wendy doesn't.
Wendy's a makeup artist, and I
think she's in Paris right now,
for Paris Fashion Week.
Her Instagram so funny,
please go on her Instagram.
I check in with Laverne
from time to time,
and she has as
grueling of a schedule.
And I think the difficult
part, what really bonds us
and connect us is that idea of
being public, private people.
And engaging with media,
and having stories,
and words and things shaped
around and then people
believing that that
is who you are.
Or the facets of you
are shown in one place,
but it's not really the
totality of who you are.
And so for me, my
goal is oftentimes
being able to show up
empty, and then also
just show up fully as who I am.
I think that we
can't do this work
without having true community.
-Thank you so much.
-Hi, I'm Emma [? Stafaroni. ?]
I'm a high school teacher
and also a compulsive
MSNBC watcher,
although I feel that I've had--
-Still?
-Still, yeah.
So this is my question.
I, like many of us in
the room, I'm sure,
have had crisis of faith
with mainstream media,
and I appreciated your points
about the way social media are
disrupting that.
But I would just love to
hear a little more from you
about your relationship
to mainstream media, now
that you have carved out this
space on MSNBC with So Popular,
and, I feel like
created a space to be
critical of the rest of
the media around you, even
on that same channel.
Especially in light
of recent news
this week, with Doctor
Melissa Harris-Perry.
So I guess I'm interested in
hearing from you about that.
-Well, what was so funny
is that I've always,
my entire life--
I don't think I've
ever worked in independent
media beyond social media,
but even that's attached to
a whole other corporation.
I'm thinking about
from when I was
at People magazine, which is the
number one magazine in America.
It's what people
read every week,
and it has lives in nail
salons to doctor's offices.
And just sits there, right.
The difficult part is
being an employee within,
and still having a
public voice to critique.
That's a line that
specifically has been difficult
this past week, in light of
Melissa Harris-Parry's show
not existing anymore.
I'm incredibly inspired
by her resistance.
Her resistance to say,
this is not the space
that I created
with my producers,
and I no longer want to
engage in this space anymore,
so I'm going to get
out of this contract.
But she also has Wake
Forest to go back home to,
so I think a lot of people
don't have that same,
I have a whole other career.
TV was fun for me to do,
but I'm done with that.
For me, I don't think I
would ever be in a space
where I feel as though I would
have to be silent about gaps
that I notice.
And I think that when I
created and pitched and hosted
So Popular, but it
was always my space,
and my space there
was to fill in gaps.
I don't think that show is
prioritized at the network
anymore, and I don't see
myself being at the network
for much longer.
-Thank you, appreciate it.
-Hi, I'm Traci Abbott.
I'm a professor of English
and Media Studies and Gender
Studies program at
Bentley University.
We've been talking about a
fixing prefixes to identities
and communities, and
how you feel about it
being a fix to movements?
Because as someone who's
worked with genderqueer
and transgender representations
for a long time,
a recent collection came
out about transfeminisms
by Anne Enke.
And it was very helpful
for me, personally,
because it bridged this
divide between queer
studies and feminist studies.
And it of course, engaged in the
conversations about feminisms.
But at the same time, calling
it transfeminism somehow
also makes it seem
distinct from feminism,
which to me is about gender
equality for all genders,
not just two genders or
people with a gender.
So I'm curious about
how you see prefixes
like that when they're fixed
to movements or disciplines
as being useful,
because they're infusing
a perspective into the
traditional definition that
makes it broader, but at
the same time maintaining
a binary between, say,
transfeminism and feminism,
as if it's a false binary.
Like they're not
on the same thing.
-I think it [INAUDIBLE]
be important
for us to be exacting in our
language about what our work
is, and what it centers.
So I would assume
in transfeminism,
the work centers trans
folk within the fight
for gender equity.
I think that if we think about
the definition of who created
and what feminism is, it often
didn't include women of color,
for example, or poor women.
And so it took a
lot of poor women,
specifically I think about
black women, like Barbara Smith,
to say, we're going to
have black feminism.
And so I think that it's OK to
have those separate spaces that
are part of this larger umbrella
of what the original term is.
I guess I'm not
bothered by people
creating their own within.
-Well, what I'm
hoping though, too,
is that if it does undermine
the concept of say,
feminism being only for
certain kinds of women.
Certain kinds of privileged
women in particular.
-But it does.
A part of it does, though.
-Right.
-That's the reality.
And so I think that it probably
was created in reaction
to being in probably such
a space that was just
seen as feminism, that didn't
want these people a part of it.
And so the radical,
revolutionary, resistant thing
is then to go and say that,
we are still a part of this,
and we'll still fight
for your liberation,
but because you're
not fighting for ours,
we need to create a space where
our liberation is centered.
And so I think that that's
what it probably came from,
because if feminism was
really for everybody, then
we wouldn't have
these other spaces.
-Thank you.
-We'll take these
two more questions.
-Together.
-Together, yes.
So ask your question, and
then we'll hear the last.
-OK.
-I think there's three there.
-Just two.
OK.
-Oh, OK.
-My name's Alicia Abbott.
I'm an author and journalist
writing on LGBTQ issues.
And I was just wanting to
return to the topic of violence
against transpeople, especially
transwomen, especially
transwomen of color,
often at the hands
of straight identified, cismen.
And I was wondering
if there need
to be more visibility
and support
for straight
identified cismen who
are attracted to
transwomen, that they
can be open about those
relationships, or so much.
If there's stigma that
provokes violence because
of rigid definitions of straight
male sexuality, what's at play?
So I just was hoping you might
be able to comment on that.
-My name's
[? Cabaseas. ?] I pass
in a number of ways, some
actively, some passively.
And hearing you talk about
passing with regard to race,
class, and gender,
I felt compelled
to make a link to assimilation.
And I'm wondering if you can
talk at all to that link.
Because I feel like
there are things
are left behind in
both situations.
So I wanted to hear
your thoughts on that.
-I feel like I spoke a little
bit about assimilation,
in the sense of talking
about shedding certain things
from my own community.
The way in which
speaking Hawaiian pidgin,
or choosing to speak in a
certain way that presents
in a better class space
in order to pull myself up
in the bootstraps, as the
Republicans would say.
So I feel like I've
touched on that.
In terms of the men
whose date transwomen
or have sex with transwomen,
I've written about this.
And I struggle often
times, because folk
are like, well
don't you think you
should create space for these
men to gather, and talk.
And I'm like, no, I don't
believe that I should create.
I think that they need
to deal with their stuff.
And I do know the
danger of also,
yes, there needs
to be a space where
men who date and have sex with
and/or fetishize transwomen
can come together, and get
each other and deal with that
and have conversations.
I believe that recently there
was a protest at the Creating
Change Conference in Chicago,
where young transwomen of color
shut down such a panel that
was created for these men.
Because one of the men was an
alleged abuser of transwomen,
and blah blah.
All that stuff, domestic partner
violence, intimate partner
violence, is real
and that oftentimes
is a part of harm that
happened to transwomen.
Also knowing that because
those men have not
created the spaces
for themselves
and probably don't
feel as if they
need to create that
space for themselves,
they are then taking
out that frustration
that they're getting from being
policed by their masculinity
and their sexuality
onto that woman
that they are in a
relationship with.
Who's already grappling
with her own stuff.
And so I feel like
that's the cycle of that.
So I do think that if there
is someone out there--
I do think that that's
a vacuum or a space that
needs to be filled.
-But not by you.
-It's just not work that
I'm committed to doing,
but I understand
the need for it.
-Yeah.
I just wonder if
it's complicated,
because you wouldn't want
to just name-- maybe they're
dating a woman who doesn't
want to disclose her trans
status, so in some
ways-- but I understand.
-What do you mean by that?
-Well I mean that there's
not a lot of visibility
for straight, identified men
who are in relationships,
and healthy relationships
with transwomen,
and that they may experience
stigmas because they
feel like they're the only one.
And so for maybe someone
come out and say,
I'm dating a transwoman,
I'm with a transwoman.
That would be
disclosing-- disclose
the status of their partner,
which would be violating
that person's privacy.
I'm just wondering about
the importance of visibility
to reduce the
stigma that might be
experienced by straight
identified trans amorous men.
-So I feel like trans
amorous is one thing.
My husband is such a man
that's-- but he's not a public
person.
But he is someone that
in the intimate part
of our relationship,
has allowed me
to write about our relationship
and our experiences.
Allowed me to let a
magazine come and photograph
our wedding.
These images, I believe, exist.
I do think that there
are other spaces, instead
of having to be public to then
grapple with those issues.
Whether that's with a social
worker or a therapist,
that's a private space
where you're not necessarily
disclosing your
partners transness.
-OK.
Thank you.
-OK, well let's
thank Janet Mock.